you know we're witty right now women in
tech international at the summit what
can we do specifically to maximize the
potential of young women into our world
I think what I believe first of all I
don't differentiate between women and
girls and boys mm-hmm I think it's a
really yes yes I think it's a really
important message to give all children
this is not about your gender this is
not about color this is not about
anything other than you as a human being
you can learn anything you want so I
would encourage hey stop being I'm a
girl or I can you know don't be afraid
just go do it
and we should support them as much as we
can which means we should support them
in the real world not separate them from
boys or gonna separate them for some you
know I I don't believe in that
separation I think you know early on
when we were raising our kids we put
computers on the floor even when they
were born and when they started crawling
they would go and you know kind of play
around with them it didn't matter so we
you know we've unfortunately for us you
know we're in a we were in a different
position but I think all of us can take
those kind of steps where we don't
differentiate that you're a girl or a
boy it takes time to get that into their
head I mean the generation that's kind
of frozen right now it's harder to
change their mindset versus the next
generation that's coming up so I highly
recommend that all adults all women go
and mentor in the cloud in their local
classrooms go and say look I am a
scientist look I am whatever I am you
know you can do it too so this is going
to take a little bit of
but I think we should be able to mentor
and everyone needs mentoring that's what
we heard at MIT Witte that's all most
women are going you need mentorship yes
so do children
I like your firm a firm you are about
human and the importance of that once we
start differentiating breaking people up
let's just call it all human and let's
call it equal opportunity to access all
these different technologies for
education and for inspiration and for
actualization for each human for each
child when they're born into the world
completely aligned with that yeah I
actually can I say something about that
I worry about you know this the
generations of say excuse me but I don't
know how to say it so I'm gonna say it
the white boy syndrome right we are
aren't we creating an unintended
consequence of say raising others by
pulling someone down mmm right this is
what the previous generations did they
you know push the minorities to stay
ahead now we want to push those and pull
them down and bring up this I think
there's got to be some other way to kind
of keep all people mm-hm find of moving
ahead and not putting pulling someone
down to the others can rise that's what
we have to find that equilibrium so that
we can actually not do unintended
consequences yeah I just I just saw a
post that was about like why can't women
hate men and I was like wait a second
yeah I was like wait a second like can
we just figure out how to all be as
humans together because you just made it
very clear like there was definitely
pushing people down to go up but now by
pushing these down to go up we're not
any better yes
any better so you know for me I think it
would be great if you know we kind of
said okay cool headed how do we all make
forward movement yes thank you and you
know there's so much stuff to be done
even these systems are you're talking
about they're not perfect we just
started out on them yeah oh my gosh and
the internet just started like yes yeah
in terms of the length of evolution and
exactly and here we are pressing our
fingers onto computers without any real
hard looks at how it's affecting our
psychology our human interaction yeah
without any hard looks at the structure
for advertising and the way that
companies make revenue but you took a
very hard look at education now I want
to just quickly make sure that you
address this because the general data
privacy rights things for becoming a
bigger deal now so students that are
under the age of 13 need a parental
consent to use the platform okay but
besides the dome previously as a
non-profit we didn't have to worry about
that hmm and I mean when you think about
this right a child under 13 comes to see
k12 and I'm going to say to that child
I'm sorry you can't learn anything until
your parent gives you permission yeah I
know right I mean the irony of that it
kills me yeah especially if the parent
hasn't is there some sort of a struggle
and the relationship between the kid and
the parent they pay the kid almost can't
act as a sovereign individual before the
age of 30 I want to know how a plane
flies yeah right yeah sorry you know
you're under 13 you can do them they
need to sign off yes and then what if
the parent says that I don't want you to
learn how the plane flies which parent
wouldn't want to do that yeah - it
almost adds a layer of complexity yeah
but it also it adds a layer of security
at the same time so it's kind of hard -
well you know I think what
what I always ask when ok Google and
Facebook I completely understand that
that you don't want your kids to be on
it all the time and whatever and who are
they're being exposed to but it's a
place like secret well yeah yeah right
where you're going to practice no you
can't practice
oh so it's almost like general data
privacy right should be a a little bit
more tailored to individual sites yes
because on Facebook it totally makes
sense exact universes on ck-12
right this is so ridiculous that you
want a child who in the moment has this
curiosity and wants to learn something
goes on a site under 13 and there's a no
you can't enter yeah yeah you can't
satisfy your curiosity